these days the next hot thing is going
to be bowling animations what if we
could make our own animations and heck
we might even be able to do it a little
bit better but we need to make sure it
has some edge that the the teams can
watch it and like think bowling's cool
again and then they got us to thinking
what if we also made them really
offensive
[Music]
two years ago nico myself and our
friends david and joe we went out
bowling to our local bowling alley in
our hometown it was a great time balls
were thrown they were rolled pins were
knocked down i love bowling jen and i
used to go like all the time but then
coveted hit and everything got shut down
and then i broke my shoulder and i
haven't really been able to go since but
i can i can bowl now see look at this
as we were bowling we realized we looked
up at the monitor there were playing
animations that corresponded to the
exact moves we were doing on the bowling
alley making these amazing little
cartoons and scenes out of them to
emphasize and hype up the excitement
that we too were feeling the thing about
those animations is that they're never
really good and i don't know if that's
like the point they look like they were
made 30 years ago it's time for some
intervention it's time for a new voice
on the bowling animation scene what if
we could make our own animations and
heck we might even be able to do it a
little bit better and then they got us
to thinking what if we also made them
really offensive how dare you mildly
offensive it would be cool to make a
complete set of these renders and then
go to a bowling alley and actually have
them use them wouldn't that be great
christian you've been talking to some
bowling alleys out here so
there's no way we're getting these
animations on the screen what
like we can't just send them like an mp4
it's literally just videos on a screen
why can't we just like go to a bowling
alley and be like hey big bowling is
literally only run by like three
companies and they all use the same
software that's like proprietary and
they all use the same animations okay so
you're saying there's like a like a
cartel
a big bowling ball
if the bowling alley ends up refusing to
use our animations we're effects artists
we're going to force it on them
digitally there's only one way we're
going to achieve this that's to be
crazier and wackier than what's already
the craziest and wackiest cg on the
planet i will show you things that you
never thought were possible from a set
of pins and balls
let's create a list here and figure out
what exactly we need to make a full set
of animations
a split is when there's two left on
either side and then you have the
europeans when you have two on each side
oh is that a thing i'll believe you sure
i'll write it i'm gonna give you the
ultimate freedom
do what inspires you do whatever you
want the only thing that matters is that
at the end of the day when we watch it
we need to feel something in here
they do say constraints make for better
creativity i do have one constraint i
think it needs to look like it was
rendered in the year 2001. no octane
rendered no redshift no arnold i want
you to use straight up old scanline
renderings i'm going to use a new render
engine i'm going to make it look
archaic
i dare you to just make it archaic from
the get-go for the sake of this let's
keep these animations anonymous that way
if one of us makes a oopsie and make
something that's too offensive we all
claim ignorance look sam don't
gutterball the entire channel okay
i'm gonna do one good gutter ball and we
can cut it we can cut it we always can
delete it later yeah
so bowling animations always look like
they were made in the 90s and i want to
capture that look now they say rather
than going out there and trying to mimic
something just shoot or do the thing
that you want to do with the proper tool
for the job you want something to look
like a shot with a vhs camera don't
shoot it with a red and then put it
through a filter shoot it on a vhs
camera you want an animation to look
like it was made in the 90s make it with
software from the 90s in this case i
didn't quite get all the way back to the
90s but i did find the oldest version of
3ds max that we had on the server still
3ds max has a renderer inside of it
called the scanline renderer and it is
super basic this is my first scene that
i built like look at those soft white
shines on the blunt ball and then the
glitchy edge of like the polygon right
there you can't make those glitches they
just have to happen naturally
i love the old-school render style but i
really want to focus on telling the
bowling jokes over the actual visual
style of it here's the hard part what do
you do for a bowling animation that's
kind of funny ha ha tasteless but not
too outright offensive what is the line
between really offensive and slightly
offensive i don't know how to ride that
line i don't try to offend anyone so
this is unusual for me i think humor at
its core is all about coping with trauma
sometimes there's a question of like how
soon is too soon how many years back do
i gotta go before it's been long enough
everyone can laugh about it so i have an
idea for how to make something slightly
offensive
with bowling and
jesus you might be asking yourself what
is this is the facade of a bank
not just any bank a bank in one of the
most ancient lands
yes tiananmen square so basically it's
got a very iconic image four tanks one
man standing in its way and just like
bowling sometimes there's that one pin
that you just can't get just like the
chinese couldn't run that one guy over
with their tank i don't know what
happened they they choked so just like
that my bowling balls are gonna choke i
don't have too much experience with 3d
modeling so of course i've got to go
asset collecting so i found this model
of jesus and i was like ah i don't like
the head so i grabbed this other model
of jesus here cut off jesus's head and
then just surgically implanting this
beautiful jesus and putting it on the
other one but i have a major problem
here and that's the fact that there are
no textures so i had an idea you know
procreate the ipad drawing app i used
for the bob ross challenge well they
just released a new update for the app
that allows you to actually import 3d
models and paint directly on them this
is the first time i've ever actually
like painted a 3d model from scratch and
it's really cool that it got to be jesus
thanks jesus i'm glad i was able to
paint you like leonardo dicaprio vinci
i came up with the idea of an airline
accident you have an airliner that's
full of bowling pins and you have
bowling balls that are basically birds
they're flying along one goes into the
jet engine the plane crashes it's a
strike congratulations he got 10 points
so i went on turbo squid and just
grabbed the freest of the free airline
models that i could find and i made like
the jankiest clouds in the background
purposely took a low resolution
environment map and like oh it's so
satisfying it's so retro it's like
authentically
bad
but you know what if the bowling masters
embrace the jank so can i the problem is
that this looks too modern and you know
what nico issued a challenge and i'm not
one to step down from challenges he said
to make it visually look like it was
released back in the early 2000s or 90s
and that means using an old-school
rendering engine called the standard
renderer in cinema 4d i guess
now it just looks like how i painted it
which was the idea to not have but you
know what there's something very freeing
about doing it this way because it looks
janky and that's okay
so i actually found this bowling pin off
of this website called sketchfab if you
use this model you have to credit this
youtube
channel all right what's your youtube
channel dude ionic animation dude he has
four subscribers you know what eonic
animation i'm gonna take your four
subscribers
so i hope this counts as credit for you
ionic i don't want to reveal too much
just yet but jesus and these pens are
going to interact if you want to see
what this looks like i guess we'll just
have to wait till everyone else sees it
the only thing i'm going to hint is that
just remember that you know jesus died
for our pens
i really decided that with gutterball it
was all about telling a story what do we
got we got booze and needles you don't
plan on ending up in the gutter you know
what i'm saying it's always through some
other mistakes in life that get you
there happens to be
heavy use of heroin for this bowling
ball look at this he is so jacked up
it's kind of tragic to be honest look
look at this guy
all alone in the gutter he's literally
in the gutter there's a little kind of
an easter egg here when he trips over
the wine bottles they're in a pin
configuration it's like metaphorical he
could have been getting a strike
but here he is in the gutter is this one
offensive i think it's more poor taste
i prefer honestly i prefer not to think
too deeply about this one or else i'm
starting to go oh there's something
wrong with me
well everybody is working on their
bowling alley animations back in the
studio i thought this would be the
perfect opportunity to tell you about
today's sponsor vessi shoes now they are
truly the perfect everyday sneaker they
are 100 water proof meaning that you can
wear them in mud snow sleet rain and
your feet are going to stay comfortable
and dry vessels are made from a patented
dymatech material which keeps you warm
in the winter and cool in the summer
they're so high tech and so comfortable
that they even know the weather if
you're into sustainably made goods well
guess what bessie is also the right
company for you because they use less
waste and use no animal byproducts they
are also one of the most flexible
sneakers that have ever been made it's
like wearing a sock they're also perfect
for every environment you can go hiking
in them you can go through urban
environments you can go in and out of
the office and especially you can wear
them bowling the bowling alley might get
mad at you because you're not wearing
those crusty nasty old sneakers that
they issue you but guess what you just
take that pair of crusty old bowling
shoes you shove them under the seat you
keep those vesses on and i guarantee you
you're going to have a better game with
a higher score than you've probably ever
had anyways if you guys are interested
in getting a pair of bessies for
yourself head on over to vesey.com
corridor crew and you will get 25 off
your purchase that's vesey.com
corridor crew enough about that let's
get back to these bowling alley
animations huge thanks to bessie for
always coming through on this channel
now let's see what the boys are cooking
up over there
all right so here at corridor we're on a
tight shift it is a thriving business
and these days the next hot thing is
going to be bowling animations but we
need to make sure it has some edge that
the the teens can watch it and like
think bowling's cool again i would love
to be able to see these animations like
on an actual bowling alley tv yeah so if
we made them good enough the bowling
alleys might actually make an exception
for us that i don't know if we're going
to be too successful with that what
maybe maybe your guys maybe your guys
i'm sorry if these are offensive i'm
apologizing now like the point was make
them slightly offensive where you didn't
have to feel like you had to apologize
are you afraid i'm a little bit afraid
i'm a little bit afraid all right all
right
let's watch some of these this is like
frame one all right so you take your
ball and you go
oh
oh gutter ball we got our ball
butterball good ball
[Music]
[Laughter]
wait what
no
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
awesome the fidelity is so good-looking
i thought we were supposed to try to
make it look like it was from the 90s
yeah i i will say it still has the air
of a bowling ball animation but i do
feel like it captures the essence of the
feeling of a gutter ball it does you
know
all right you got this man
[Music]
right down the middle is a perfect
strike let's go
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i love how crappy this looks
i've purposely left in glitches it's
like
zooming
the flames look so bad i love it
you nailed the look this yeah this feels
like straight out of the 90s thank you i
got 10 points we'll see what happens the
next frame
i'm hoping to get a strike i'm just
going to trust in jesus
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i'm a little concerned because my wife's
mom is a pastor so
i hope she's not offended i think she'll
appreciate it oh jordan yeah
freaking strike baby
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow
this is a high effort animation right
here the eyeball
is going down that lips you got slurpy
eyes you're making me jealous with that
animation wow i should have rendered
mine out at worst quality
matt europe
oh dang i got the legendary 7 10 split
the hardest one to do i have to choose
one pin what's gonna happen
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
foreign
you made like an art film out of that
man your brain would be so messed up
after going bowling at this japanese
i love that you went like the high
fidelity rendering route it looks really
nice and of course if this gets accepted
at a bowling alley we'll have two
animations right i'm a bit apprehensive
to submit it to a bowling alley because
we're kind of in the finals for sundance
and so
all right frame two i throw the ball
whoa
it got
all of the pins you got straps except
one
oh man
[Music]
the aesthetic is so good
it's so good what does that say uh it
says nine
all right because sam left that one pin
well i'm gonna have to knock it down
let's see if i can nail a spare
look out
oh it's perfect i just nailed it
[Applause]
oh my god the style of rendering is so
good
[Music]
wow man
here's
honestly there's definitely something to
doing this in 3ds max it has that
certain quality i think i've had a few
too many pictures at this point so
i'm gonna just do my best not to get a
gutter ball
oh i almost got a gutterball but i got
one you got one
no metaphors at all
oh
[Laughter]
the body except for the head is just
mickey mouse i just ripped a mickey
mouse model oh that's why they're gloves
[Laughter]
[Music]
this one is a
strike
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for taking a stand
there's only uh there's only one turn
left in this bowling game and it's
jordan's turn here we go
for all the marbles
i hit one i only have one two
oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh my god jordan it was a pleasure
working with you it really was i was
looking for the line and i think i found
it i found none of these animations
offensive except for this one can we
show this on youtube i don't know if we
can put this one on youtube this is
offensive it's insulting to watch
because of how shitty it is in in both
literal and metaphorical ways i did
really enjoy all of those those are
hilarious natalie oh my god you made a
full-on short film that was incredible
yeah the suicide divorce combo really
makes it you know so you know if you
guys uh see any other areas that are
really in need of some really tone-deaf
animations just leave a comment down
below suggesting it to us
maybe like movie theaters movie theaters
need like the cool like squishy theater
popcorn intro but slightly offensive
movie theater intro that spoils every
big like movie
[Laughter]
i don't know where i heard really
offensive i heard it though okay check
the tape
and then they got us to thinking what if
we also made them really offensive
okay
we're so sorry
look if we can't cover these horrific
topics and bowling animations when
you're out bowling with friends if we
can't have these conversations then when
can we have them you know
like and subscribe thank you
oh my bye
oh that's so good